[Music]
vsauce
kevin here your vsauce 2 friend your
college friend the friend of a friend
you met at a party
a family reunion a concert an online
forum dedicated to
japanese role-playing games but am i
really
your friend probably not
[Music]
why because we don't like the same music
or
movies because you wouldn't invite me to
your wedding
no because your brain is full
while studying primates social systems
psychologist robin dunbar found a
correlation between the size of the
neocortex
and the size of the average social group
the larger the neocortex the larger the
group size
by extrapolating his findings and
applying them to humans
he arrived at a cognitive limit for the
amount of complex
mutually affectionate social
relationships a person's brain
can handle a research guideline for the
number of real friends
you can have a literal friend zone
of 150.
number so who are all these
facebook friends i'm not actually
friends with by pooling everyone in your
social network into one tub
labeled friends facebook oversimplifies
your relationships
your mom your best friend from high
school and your brother's former boss
you met once at a company picnic
are all incorrectly assigned the same
level
of intimacy your actual social network
would look less like a tub
and more like a series of buckets
high school friends neighbors work
friends from various jobs nuclear family
extended family online friends family
friends
people you literally don't know how you
became facebook friends with
you know these are separate hubs because
mixing them
gets awkward it's why seating charts at
weddings get
complicated your college buddies and
your grandma tilly not
only have little in common but they're
likely friends with a different
you and the intimacy of these
friendships occur roughly in concentric
circles separated
by a factor of three you probably have
about five of your closest friends
formerly referred to as your support
clique people you speak with
every week in fact eighty percent of
phone calls are made to the same four
people
about 12 to 15 can make up your sympathy
group
people who would be devastated if you
died
you could probably handle about 50
meaningful relationships
and a maximum of 150 currently active
friendships
here's the weird part dunbar calculated
this human friendship limit based on
neocortex size in relation to primate
group size
it turns out it's like the shadowy
secret of
human cooperation
no really a study of the 20 tribal
societies with available census data
showed a mean
clan group size of 153. dunbar and
fellow evolutionary anthropologist
russell hill
examined the exchange of christmas cards
in the uk and found a maximum network
size
of 153.5 a 2008 survey of the not
wedding network of over 18 000 brides
revealed an average wedding guest total
of 148. the roman army during the
republic utilized a fighting unit called
the maniple with 130 to 140 soldiers and
officers while in modern militaries a
company tops
out at about 150 middle eastern
neolithic villages dating back to 6000
bc
usually populated between 120 to 150
while the doomsday book of 1086 one of
the oldest
population surveys commissioned by king
william the conqueror for tax collecting
purposes
reveals an estimated english village
size around
150. even into the 18th century the
average english village had about 160
residents
today the hutterite and amish community
split if the group exceeds 150.
bill gore split his gore-tex factories
by 150 to keep his employees functioning
in personal cooperative relationships
a 2011 study of 1.7 million twitter
users found they maintain a stable
relationship with 100 to 200 individuals
the average number of facebook friends
is between 150
and 200. when an nfl team wins the super
bowl guess how many rings are awarded
150. wait
so if every person outside my 150 is
just some sort of casual acquaintance
then what's a friend and why do we have
them
and do we need them
and well that's enough questions for now
billy just
relax relationship quality and the
cognitive complexity involved in
managing friendships
means it's not just memorizing human
trivia like how one person relates to
another and how they both relate to you
that judy's favorite food is beef
stroganoff
or the latest gossip about stan dumping
sarah for sally because sarah snuck out
with steve sasselberry on saturday and
they smooched
[Laughter]
a friend requires the presence of a
social bond like
routinely removing ticks
the purpose of mutual grooming in
primates is not just about picking
parasites but also about reducing stress
and forming and maintaining social
structure
not for fun for survival
the social intelligence hypothesis
states that the need for understanding
and managing relationships
is the key identifier separating
primates from other animals
and there's a correlation between group
size complex social worlds and the
relative size of the neocortex
the layer of the brain responsible for
cognition
and language the need to live in larger
groups for the survival of the species
may have driven humans to develop the
largest relative neocortex
on the planet i'm able to form words and
communicate with you
you clicked on this video to watch and
listen
to me our brains evolved to satisfy our
need to survive
which required forming relationships
with each other
look if we're gonna live on the ground
in open habitats and there are snakes
lions and dingos out there we better
have each other's backs
and probably a pointy stick or
something
but the internet has made practically
the entire world our social habitat
so how do we categorize sort build and
maintain relationships with
everyone we've ever met and everyone
we're
ever going to meet social media has
allowed us to expand our access to
casual relationships and to build our
network of loosely known
acquaintances but analysis of facebook
friends surveys showed the inner layers
of an
individual's online social network just
reflects the size of it
offline the internet isn't allowing us
to pass the limit of dunbar's number
friendship requires an ongoing mutual
connection
it's not just a voyeuristic one-way
relationship with your favorite youtuber
even though you feel like you know
everything about them phil defranco
isn't going to pick you up from the
airport at 3 o'clock in the morning
what i totally pick you up from the
airport wait really
no oh
it's important to note that the specific
150 number is not a hard and fast
cut off but a guideline for the
cognitive abilities required
to track individual traits and
preferences in complex social
relationships
some people may have a limit of 100
while others can maintain
up to 250 active friendships and
dunbar's number is not a suggestion for
how many total friends you should have
you could have two and that's totally
fine you just can't have
more than your limit it's not just some
memory barrier a
jeopardy champion can't magically juggle
900 affectionate relationships
it's also about the time required to
invest in a friendship to maintain an
emotional
interpersonal link we have a fixed
amount of emotional capital we can
spread out among a bunch of people
or to invest more heavily in a smaller
amount and the time needed to keep
relationships going
is what can turn an old best friend into
just somebody that you used to know
like that song somebody
that i used to know what's changed about
living in a time where you can have
5 000 facebook friends isn't the number
of people you can be friends with
it's the number of people who could be
your friend by opening up
communication to the world we put life
preservers on real friendships of the
past as we swim deeper into a sea of
people we'd never have been able to meet
before
and it's changing how we do i
do marriage was typically a social or
economic union arranged or sanctioned by
families to bolster their survival
according to historian stephanie coons
for thousands of years
marriage had very little to do with
individual relationships between the
bride
and groom it was really a way of turning
strangers
into relatives a way of sticking new
people
to your social web of integrating new
balls into your ball pit today in the
u.s
a third of marriages start online i'm
sure many of you have close friends you
only know
from a distance by breaking down
barriers of time and space
we've unlocked meaningful connections
unparalleled
in human history for thousands of years
we were tethered to
and maybe even evolved to maintain
relationships with the roughly 150
people we
happened to be born around and the
families we
married into you were born in that
social ball pit now there are over 3
billion people connected to the internet
ready and waiting for a place in your
life
a spot in your 150
which doesn't seem like much
does it until you realize how amazing it
is to
share your banana with a stranger
while chimpanzees will kill other chimps
outside their social group for resources
a duke university study found that
bonibos will share
food with strangers in order to expand
their social network
bats dolphins elephants and many
primates share with members of their own
group
but the bonabeau is offering up banana
slices to total strangers over members
of their in-group
in the hopes of making a friend
the human propensity to share has long
baffled us from an evolutionary
perspective
why give your banana to a stranger
but it now seems at least one other
species has seen the survival benefit
in finding new friends
anyone who's faced personal hardship
knows how life-saving those friends
can be there's a sentiment regarding
friendship that's been passed down for
millennia from aristotle's successor
theophrastus
to 19th century british literary critic
john
curtin collins in prosperity
our friends know us in
adversity we know our friends
[Music]
and whether you have 2 10 or 150
those friends you know when facing
adversity
when things aren't going well
are forged with a bond so rare
it's millions of years in the making
want a banana and as always
thanks for watching
so at the end of my video on the
invention of blue i featured an animated
gif from the ludicrously talented
kidmograph
well he has a class on skillshare
that'll teach you how to make 80s
inspired animated gifs
skillshare has over 17 000 classes in
design
video editing and more an annual
subscription is less than 10 bucks a
month
the first 200 people to use the promo
link in the description
get their first two months for free so
check out what skillshare has to teach
you
check out this playlist for more vsauce2
so you can keep learning about being
human
[Music]
being thanks for watching
you